most parents feel safe letting their
kids accompany them to see the latest
marvel blockbuster but there's also
plenty of mcu content that's meant just
for the grown-ups with that in mind here
are a few things only adults will notice
in chongqi in the legend of the ten
rings
on a dark desert highway cool wind in my
hair those 10 words from katie and the
scaffolding scene will almost certainly
resonate with every adult in the
shanghai audience who can't help but
recognize the introductory line to one
of the most popular songs in 20th
century adult-oriented album rock
written and performed by the eagles
released in 1977 on the album of the
same name hotel california won the
grammy for record of the year and soared
to the number one position on the
billboard charts of course kids in the
chongqi audience won't know any of this
as it seems unlikely they're sleeping
under a don henley poster on the bedroom
wall however hotel california has become
an inescapable part of the american
songbook you might not be rocking the
eagles on spotify but you're no less
destined to hear the song in an elevator
at the bank or you know featured
prominently in one of the year's biggest
blockbuster movies of course the song
comes around again later on when the
good guys have triumphed and katie and
sean want to celebrate with wong and
some karaoke
like the eagles connection chongqi and
the legend of the ten rings is stuffed
with references more likely to make mom
and dad laugh than the kids but what
marvel always does well is write these
lines so everyone can understand the
context regardless of their pop culture
prowess then again pop culture is
stretching things when katie makes
passing reference to talbots a 74 year
old american specialty retailer with
more than 400 locations nationwide the
store is best known for being the go-to
place to grab a holiday gift card for
your grandmother in another scene shawn
is called gangnam style this attempted
slur compared him to psy the worldwide
sensation who in 2012 set a world record
for having the first clip on youtube to
surpass a billion views as of 2021 the
gangnam style music video had reached 4
billion views and was the 10th most
viewed and 5th most liked video on
youtube sean explains that this is both
insensitive and ignorant since he's
chinese and psy is from south korea
kitty also references jeff gordon one of
the most influential and decorated
drivers in the history of nascar
currently an announcer for fox nascar
gordon is a four-time cup series
champion three-time winner of the
daytona 500 and became the youngest
driver to win a nascar title at the age
of 24. as it turns out the reference is
a bit of foreshadowing as katie's
obvious enthusiasm for racing later
manifests itself in some slick moves
behind the wheel of razer fist's car
while our heroes navigate the magically
shifting jungle around tallow
to understand the true origins of
chongqi you have to go back to a time
and place comic books in the early 1970s
when the character first appeared in
special marvel edition number 15 in 1973
marvel was dominating the industry but
saw growth potential elsewhere writing
the martial arts craze kicked off by
bruce lee and his huge hit enter the
dragon it's easy now to look back on
those movements as condescending
money-grabbing largely white financed
efforts to co-op heartfelt sentiment
it's also undeniable that for the first
time in popular culture asian american
audiences were seeing themselves on
screen not as punchlines and purse
snatchers but as heroes which isn't to
say those shang-chi adventures have aged
well he was originally presented as the
son of foo manchu a character who
perpetuated yellow peril stereotypes the
early comics often portrayed chongqi as
subservient kicking butt in battle but
requiring guidance in social situations
as a result of these and other issues in
the character's problematic history
writer dave callahan has revealed that
the behind the scenes team for chongqi
created a list of racist stereotypes
they were determined to quote destroy
while scripting the movie
in sean's modest department at the
beginning of the film he has all the
essentials of bachelor life a bed a tv
space to do push-ups he also has some
cool posters adorning his walls which
might allude to themes director destin
daniel creighton was attempting to tap
into for his marvel debut one of the
posters is for 2004's kung fu hustle
written and directed by stephen chao
it's a chinese action comedy that
follows an aspiring gangster a poor
village and the colorful characters that
orbit them often lumped in with
crouching tiger hidden dragon and hero
is modern examples of wu shot films that
have caught on with american audiences
the film is nonetheless unique in that
it brandishes a sense of humor not
present in the others as it turns out it
is a tone very similar to the one struck
by chongqi as well a guy with a freaking
machete foreign arm
just chopped our butts in half oh yeah
it also features a character who
specializes in fighting with iron rings
another poster is perhaps less of an
obvious influence on chongqi and the
legend of the ten rings but no less
classic of a film it's walter hills the
warriors which is about a near
futuristic new york ruled by eccentric
gangs considered a cult classic the film
contains brutal violence a gleeful
nihilistic attitude and style to spare
sure they look cool in the movie but
some adults watching may know that iron
rings are a real part of multiple
martial arts disciplines especially kung
fu hustle fans watch any video of a kung
fu master using iron rings and you'll
get an idea of how they can add
resistance to arm movements hardening
muscle and strengthening the arms and
fist of combatants warning they are
extremely noisy so you might want to
leave them at home if you're hoping to
preserve the element of surprise against
your opponent of course real-life iron
rings won't allow the user to throw
fireballs climb up them like steps or
throw them like boomerangs but if the
non-magical kind were good enough for
bruce lee that'd probably help with your
training as well
i actually did take a little bit of
martial arts as a youth so i'm going to
try and grade this fight as we're going
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
chongqi are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one